hey guys in some of my videos I explain
to you why it is important to choose
quality of a quantity when it comes to
style and when we look at shoes nothing
beats quality handcrafted shoes and so
in today's video I'm gonna show you four
different types of shoes that's Italian
handcrafted high quality shoes it's
gonna be unboxing video let's get to it
[Music]
alright now for a while now I've been
wanting to show you guys high quality
handcrafted shoes that you can get at a
more affordable price compared to the
high and you know those kind of brands
where you just pay for the brand name
and not so much just for the shoes so I
talked with ace Marx that makes
top-quality handcrafted Italian shoes
and they agreed to sponsor this video
for you guys so let me show you their
shoes
[Music]
so here we are we got four pairs of
shoes and then they also sent me a pair
of socks which is pretty awesome
it says ace marks one size mercerized
Egyptian cotton crafted in Italy and
when we look at the back it says 80%
cotton 15% pull em ID and 5% liquor
alright thank you guys so much so they
don't just do shoes they also do shoes
accessories so then we got a nice shoe
care kit over here let's have a look
[Music]
this is nice so we got some polish over
here we got a shoehorn here we got a
cloth and then we also got these brushes
over here so this is all you need to
really take care of your shoes awesome
thank you guys so much I'm definitely
gonna use this now let's have a look at
the shoes number one let's have a look
all the boxes look the same right it's
very clean it's an elegant and it says
ace marks hand crafted in Italy let's
have a look okay so first up you get
this guy over here ace marks handcrafted
in Italy and it says something
interesting here important for returns
and exchange we can only accept unwarned
shoes without scuffs or other damage
alright let's have a look inside where
we get it here oh I see it's a shoe back
so when you travel you can put your
shoes in here so this is pretty awesome
very neat I'm definitely gonna use this
when I travel all right let's have a
look at the shoes what do we have oh my
goodness
[Music]
black Chelsea boots oh my goodness
you can feel and well it looks like
quality as well but you can feel the
quality of these shoes you can never go
wrong with chelsea boots when it comes
to style and these are just perfect now
they also come with a nice shoehorn
which is pretty neat as it very cool Wow
[Music]
all right let's have a look at the next
one all right boxing is exactly the same
as the first one another shoehorn
so yes you get a shoehorn with it get
this guy again get another bag as well
for the shoes awesome let's see what do
we have all right here we go guys the
brown double monk strap shoes these are
a classic 100% leather and man you can
just feel that they are made to be worn
by a real gentleman because they are
just so elegant hmm Wow
oh my goodness guys oh these are amazing
stunning all right next one
yeah the penny loafers in Navy suede now
this is not a style that everybody would
like but it has a very elegant shape and
it will definitely add class to any
outfit you'd wear plus it is easy and
very comfortable to wear because of its
easy slip-on design so if you haven't
tried it yet maybe it's time you did
[Music]
let's have a look at the next one all
right this is the last one so let's
check it out okay so you get the same
with the other shoes but you get extra
shoelaces as well
[Music]
now this is luxury black dress sneakers
and got these white out souls and this
is why they gave the white shoe laces so
you have another option if you don't
like the black it's so cool I wish you
guys could feel this because you can
feel real 100% Italian leather and yet
it is so comfortable another interesting
thing is that you can see here that
they're white out soles they're not
glued but they're stitched which shows
you that is made of real quality so this
is clearly an all-purpose sneaker that
well it just screams of quality and
comfort
[Music]
alright guys so I tried on all of these
shoes from ace marks and they fit 100%
and I gave them the the measurements of
my feet only a few weeks ago and they
made my shoes and shipped them to me a
lot faster than I expected and I'm from
South Africa so things always takes a
little bit longer to arrive here so well
done ace marks I'll add their
information for you in the video
description so you can go and check them
out as well so what I'm gonna do for you
guys is I'm gonna wear these shoes for a
couple of weeks and I'm gonna test them
out and then I'm gonna make an honest
review for you guys as always so if you
like this video give it a thumbs up
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
video